un diagnostic de cancer est toujours
difficile à recevoir et des traitements
parfois éprouvant dans le code la
radiothérapie une nouvelle approche
pourrait faire en sorte qu'une seule
dose soit suffisante pour traiter
certains cancers du sein le cancer
il nous propulse malgré-nous sur la voie
d'un long parcours d'abord consacré au
traitement
les premiers pas sont éprouvants
normalement quand y'a un traitement
complet avec la chine au pyla
radiothérapie la passante
malheureusement doit s'absenter pendant
un an le temps c'est ce qu'on lui donne
comme arrêt de travail ce qui est énorme
une fois sur deux l'espoir d'une
guérison passe par des traitements de
radiothérapie
il peut avoir 15 20 30 séances de
radiothérapie tout ce parcours leur peut
facilement prendre un homme
et si on pouvait réduire le nombre de
traitements et bien c'est ce que permet
maintenant la radiothérapie portative
autrefois on a mené le patient en
radiothérapie
aujourd'hui celle inverse dans les
appareils de résoudre a dit c'est des
gros appareils en général sont coulés
dans le béton du plancher on ne pouvait
pas le déplacer pour s'ajuster aux
patients l'ont un appareil qui est quand
même assez présent mais qu'on peut
déplacer dans les ascenseurs de
l'obstacle à la limite qu'on pourrait
déplacer en deux blocs opératoires
devenu portatif
l'appareil permet une chose incroyable
faire de la radiothérapie durant la
chirurgie
la patiente qui est éligible arrivent de
l'extérieur puis en un traitement entre
guillemets c'est un one stop shop et
tout son traitement à part la chimio si
nécessaire et déjà terminée c'est un
gros avantage aux patientes qui pourrait
retourner au travail
quatre semaines après
[Musique]
montréal février 2021
le cancer du sein de la patient est
localisé le docteur yunnan retire la
masse tumorale
mais il sait qu aux pourtours de la
plaie pourrait se trouver des cellules
tumorales des cellules source de
récidive et il faut se rappeler de façon
historique que les récidives arrive dans
le même cadre en donc autour de la
tumeur à 80 pour 100 ml
normalement à cette étape le docteur
yunnan doit refermer la plaie des mois
plus tard son collègue amorcera la
radiothérapie
mais aujourd'hui c'est différent
avec son équipe le docteur roberge
s'assure du bon déroulement du
traitement qui faut-il le rappeler est
une première canadienne
son collègue tu as les tissus en santé
ce qui pourrait se retrouver dans la
mire du faisceau donc au lieu dit radier
tout le saint et de causer des effets de
radiation à toute la glande est au sein
au complet on l'élite sans toucher la
peau du tout puisque l'appareil est à
l'intérieur du sein et on les limites
dans le temps pour donner un seul
traitement la journée de la chirurgie et
non pas deux trois quatre cinq semaines
pour minimiser les effets liés à
l'irradiation on dépose au fond de la
plaie une plaque en acier inoxydable
on a un bouclier qui protège derrière au
niveau du serl et qui empêche toute
radiation au niveau du poumon et au
niveau du cas donc beaucoup moins
d'effets secondaires
absolument aucun effet au niveau de la
peau du sein qui est donc protégé à 100%
en là ça va être le jeu de vraiment
l'installer pour ne pas qu'ils bougent
du tout la précision étant au millimètre
pour pâques et de mouvement on remodèle
le tissu mammaire on le place pour que
le pourtour de la plaie se retrouve à
l'extrémité du collimateur
la position est parfait et le autonome
des complètement dans le vert martin
voyer l'enlèvement des deux de koné
matters et le concentrateur d'électrons
et donc la radio n'a pu être donné dans
quelques milles fille on va sortir de la
salle fondement
[Musique]
c'est un go on irradie la plaie le
faisceau composé d'électrons tue les
cellules cancéreuses celle invisibles à
l'oeil nu
le tour est joué en 60 secondes à l'opt
et endormie une demi heure de plus là
c'en est pas rendu compte
son conjoint qui l'attendait le haut
dans la salle d'attenté attendu de
devenir le plus à se réveiller son
traitement est finie pourquoi est ce
qu'on peut faire un traitement au lieu
de 15 à une question de temps
le la tumeur on le pôle laisser
progresser pendant un autre deux mois ça
qu'on a peut-être besoin d'un peu moins
de rayonnement il ya une question
physique ou s'il ya des organes qui
limite combien qu'on peut donner de
réellement par jour ça que les poumons
le car la peau si on peut complètement
exclure c'est tu le du faisceau on peut
se permettre de donner seulement qu
entraînement pour l'instant on limite la
radiothérapie portative aux patients qui
ne requiert aucune chimiothérapie donc
tu me dépasse a donc ménopausées des
passeurs avec des tumeurs de moins que
deux centimètres puis avec une biologie
pas agressifs et donc avec un taux de
récidive locale un peu plus faible et
pas d'atteinte au niveau des ganglions
en dessous du bras d'un cancer du sein
c'est là qu'on voit programme a le plus
grand pourcentage des patientes qui
pourraient bénéficier de se tenir le
choc
au delà des avancées que permet cet
appareil la radiothérapie vit une
période excitante de nouvelle étude
laisse présager que nous sommes à la
veille d'une révolution
on a compris récemment que si au lieu de
le donner sur des minutes on le donne
sur une fraction de seconde
l'effet biologique qui est différent on
tue plus d'un cancer pour moins de
dommages aux tissus sains
ça pourrait être une révolution du
traitement du cancer si on s'imagine
tous les patients qu'on a un qui
viennent pour un traitement
il est vrai pour une demi seconde puis
le traitement sera fini
ça serait vraiment spectaculaire on est
au tout début de cette vague là mais ça
peut aller assez à sévir faire